backlash is growing over Kevin Spacey's
response to a sexual misconduct
allegation the International Academy of
Television Arts and Sciences is revoking
Spacey's 2017 International Emmy
Founders Award and a growing number of
celebrities and organizations are now
condemning him actor Anthony Rapp says
that he was 14 when Spacey made unwanted
sexual advances toward him Spacey
apologised to rap and in this same
statement came out as gay Jericka Duncan
is here with a criticism over that
timing Jericka good morning good morning
amid the scandal Netflix announced that
house of cards starring Kevin Spacey
will end after the sixth season which is
in production now but sources say that
decision was made months ago in a joint
statement Netflix and the series
producers say they are deeply troubled
by allegations against their lead actor
house of cards star Kevin Spacey is
facing harsh criticism from Hollywood
and a gay community over his apology to
actor Anthony Rapp I was told to expect
a Vulcan there may be a misunderstanding
rap a Broadway veteran who was now
featured in Star Trek discovery told
BuzzFeed news that he remembers Spacey
picking him up and putting him on the
bed and then laying down on top of him
it allegedly happened after a New York
party more than thirty years ago when
rap was just 14 Spacey says he doesn't
remember the incident but apologized for
any inappropriate drunken behavior he
then revealed he is gay Daniel Reynolds
is senior editor at The Advocate an LGBT
interest magazine Kevin Spacey took
which should be a proud and joyous
moment which is an after coming out and
he's conflated it with something like
sexual assault this doesn't help the
conversation raps accusation comes amid
a wave of harassment claims against
NBC's Mark Halperin director James
Toback and movie mogul Harvey Weinstein
Weinstein subsequently resigned from The
Producers Guild of America which on
Monday banned him for life Spacey's
apology was scrutinized by other gay
actors including Wanda Sykes Billy
Eichner Rosie O'Donnell George Takei and
Zachary Quinto went
called Spacey statement a calculated
manipulation to deflect attention from a
very serious accusation in a way I think
a lot of people feel it like that's
another kind of silencing of a victim
the president of GLAAD a gay rights
organization also condemned Spacey
statements saying this is not a
coming-out story about Kevin Spacey but
a story of survivorship by Anthony Rapp
and all those who bravely speak out
against unwanted sexual advances Nora
alright sharika thank you so much